all right y'all we back live you know
how we
do ladies and
gentlemen welcome to you
know your favorite
[Music]
podcast
w
[Music]
g with
Griffin
[Music]
yeah welcome back to Griffin with
[Applause]
Griffin your boy Eric Griffin
today I want to I want to get caught up
on the NBA the
NFL I'm watching this weird ass
documentary called mother God on HBO I
got a new computer I want to talk about
that there's some weird news in notes on
the uh internet I love doing that but
once again we're back and you know how
we do it as always
[Music]
y'all yeah y'all welcome back to riffin
with Griffin um what's going on y'all
wait how come my story didn't um uh
upload well whatever I uploaded a story
welcome back to ref oh I even have it on
the wrong thing too it's supposed to be
on man I'm telling you I'm just like on
one
today because I got a new computer so
it's like all like messing me up but
yeah here's my page I like to be on when
I start the show so sorry so there it is
right there riffin with Griffin thanks
for being here you know how we do uh
make sure guys you hit the Subscribe
button that would be great you know
subscribe
subscribe to riffin with Griffin so you
know I get that uh subscribe you know
how you twitch we on Twitch daily you
know how we do it there too let's see
how do you this new comp the new uh Max
you can't go to like the sound thing in
the um up on the uh the the the status
bar so that's weird anyways but you can
hear me so we're good uh and you know as
always you know know I always talk about
new content coming it's so
hard at this point look you're
supporting me and I appreciate it but I
guarantee you when when it does when it
does happen you're gonna be like man
because I'm really thinking about doing
a different format as I'm closing in on
300 episodes but I'll talk about that
right now we'll just talk about it so if
you want to support this show you could
be a sub on Twitch that's the best place
to do it sub on Twitch YouTube member or
patreon I appreciate all that
support
um yeah
so uh let's see oh let's see what are
you saying here what's up Eric we're
getting audio in the left ear oh you're
only getting audio in one ear huh I oh
wow okay I could fix that so sorry for
people listening
you you know I got a new computer so I
got to set it up properly I know what it
is I know how to fix it hold up y'all I
know how to fix this now now baby
baby and here we are in both ears you
get me in Stereo and it was like we was
like 1960 remember I don't know if the
older people that listen to my podcast
if you guys remember that they used to
do like they used to think stereo was
like like certain sounds in the left ear
certain sounds in the right ear so you
might have the drums in the left ear and
then you know then they figured out how
to do stereo and the stereo sound and
all that kind of stuff so I just had the
wrong thing checked cuz you know when
you when you get a new computer you have
have to like change um you have to
change it
so but thank you everybody thanks for uh
you know keeping me accountable on the
the the tech
front so welcome back to riffin with
Griffin um what's what's new you know
what's new is I got a new computer I'm
just going to do my Mac Mini review
right up top so I had an Intel iMac for
years you know the thing about computers
you buy a computer on Monday and by
Friday it's already
obsolete they've come out with the new
technology so you know the Intel Mac uh
back in the day they're pretty expensive
cuz I think Mac was had a deal with so
they had to pay the licensing to uh uh
Intel I don't know if it worked like
that but it just seemed like it worked
like that so you know those those Macs
were kind of expensive you know you can
get you can get up to four five $6,000
when you want to get the the proper
thing so then Apple they came out with
their own chip this m M1 series but they
never came out with the iMac for it so I
never I kept my IM Mac and then it came
out with this Mac Mini but I wasn't sure
if I wanted it or not see one thing I'm
not a computer geek and so the computer
geeks out there can help me with this
but I got to say man there was something
that used to frustrate the hell out of
me about Max so I remember when I bought
and I think I talked about this on many
episodes ago on the podcast but I just
you know this is important for this now
but I remember buying the iMac right and
I'm in the store and you know I say it I
say well is this going to work I stream
this the stuff I do oh it's going to be
fun you right and what it was is it's
about the ram now this is bananas to me
okay this is absolutely bananas to me
and I think it's a scam that Apple has
been running on us for since their
existence okay so you could get a iMac
let's say back in the day and it it
could have two terabytes of space uh
this super fast super fast processor
quote unquote for the people listen I
got my air quotes up super fast
processor all this stuff and it'll have
but it can have 16 megabytes of ram I
don't know what Ram is I don't
understand why Ram has such a huge
effect on the computer but I brought it
home and this 16 Megs of ram my computer
couldn't do [__] I couldn't have like
Photoshop open let's say with my mail
and then be checking websites it was
just slow as hell and I was like how is
this computer slow and you're telling me
that 16 more Megs of ram going up to 32
makes the computer be night and day
that's [__] to me that is [__]
it's a total scam and then they charge
you you know $500 more for more RAM 600
whatever the price is it's usually like
$600 more for this 16 megabytes of ram
to probably cost them $50 at most to
make the computer usable it's so
ridiculous and I think most people out
there they probably you buy that and
you're like why is my computer slow and
you don't even understand like why is my
computer slow this don't even make sense
right but that's what it is man it's so
frustrating you know what I mean it's
like super frustrating so anyways cut to
the M1 Mac comes out and it's I see the
16 megabytes of ram so I'm like uhoh is
this going to be the same issue and then
now I don't trust the people at the Mac
the Apple Store to tell me like it's if
you know is this really going to work
for the things that I do look I stream
I'm doing my podcast live from my
computer right now so I just wasn't sure
and then I just do a bunch of research
you know for you know for the last year
I've been like asking people and like
checking it out and then they came out
with the M2 you know so they have this
M2 uh one now with higher processor you
know I got the I still got the 32 Megs
of ram which I they now you can go to
like 96 or whatever it is like that so I
just don't understand if somebody could
explain to me in the comments why is it
the ram that dictates everything about
the computer you know it just doesn't
make any sense Random Access Memory
that's what it's called thank you I
don't understand it I don't because like
if that's the case then that should be
the most important thing is it the
processor is it the the you know what I
mean is it the hard drive space like the
ram seems to be the most singular
important thing in the computer that
makes it operate at a speed that you
just go oh wow my computer is zipping
around so I got this Mac Mini it's
really little which I what I like about
it you know like it's actually portable
if I wanted to take it on the road with
me I could you know it's got like a HDMI
out so you just put that out to all you
could put that probably put that out to
the TV or if you have a little monitor
that you want to bring with you or you
could have like a little streaming thing
then you can just hook it right into
your computer I don't know your other if
you have a la a laptop or something to
use oh actually you could just use your
other your laptop as a monitor so the
new Mac operating system this is pretty
cool so I had my iMac and then I had you
know I have these two monitors here you
know so I use one for gaming one for
like stuff while I'm doing it right and
then I had my iMac so while I was
working with the Mac Mini trying to
transfer things over and making sure I
had everything on the new computer my
mouse I noticed I went to like display
and all on the new Mac Mini the iMac
showed up as a display so it was like
all three of them were working together
int and the mouse and keyboard was
connected to all of them I was like like
mind blown so like this new Mac software
is pretty great so like if you had your
laptop sitting next to your computer um
it would just recognize it and all of a
sudden now the mouse and keyboard would
work for all of it so I think that's
pretty dope in terms of the new
operating system I don't know which what
they're on they always have some weird
Apple name for them but I would say this
Mac Mini is a great computer the only
thing the only downside because you can
get like you don't have to spend an
amount of money that I spent because I
spent about $2,000 on this right you
could get a you know a lesser version
operate cuz depending on what you're
doing with it and they're still very
apparently they're super powerful you
know the only downside is you have to
buy a good Monitor and that that's where
they get you so if you want to buy the
Mac monitor that sucker is
expensive you know they're like $1,500
just for like this like so I don't know
I kind of suggest you like go to like
Best Buy look on Amazon and find
yourself like a good good gaming monitor
with you know High megahertz and and
refresh rate and just use that as
opposed to spending $1500 on the Mac so
that is the one thing that I was like uh
I don't know about about that but I
still have these monitors and I'm not
super happy with my monitors but for
what it does um you know I'm happy with
it right now so anyways that's what's
going on there with My Little Mac mini
um yeah so I see somebody in the chat
talking about it Ram is my buddy Chris
uh wait that's my is that my that's my
producer guy makes aot lot of great
beats right you what's up man Ram is
what is best used by applications like
Chrome Excel gaming Etc uh Chrome web
browsers can use 500 megabytes of ram of
the total your yeah like that's what I'm
saying so like you know you got to have
good Ram because some of these
applications turn on and it just bogg
down your system you know but I just
give you an example so I have my web
browser going right now I have my
wirecast which I'm streaming to you guys
and I have a bunch of websites open
that's how I look to get my information
while I'm online with you guys and then
I my this this uh program wirecast will
tell me my CPU usage so right now I'm at
31% CPU usage and that's pretty great
considering all this stuff that I have
going on right now so you
know um yeah somebody says Sean Canada
in the chat said those monitors are
great for digital artists and I totally
get that like you know if you're a
graphic designer or something like that
or you or you're a movie editor you want
to have like actual what it looks like
on the screen is what it's going to look
like because then you would be off
you're like editing like color and and
stuff and then you look and you're like
oh this looks great and then somebody
would a really good monitor or what it's
going to look like on the screen per se
they're like well this is off or what
it's going to look like on people TVs on
their 4K TVs you're going to be like
what the hell are you talking
about um so
anyways that's that that's my uh little
update about my computer Mac Mini which
is uh you know going good see what else
is going on so Rachel going strong guys
we're getting so close end of January uh
you know life will change for me um uh
and I'm sure for the better so you know
nothing really to report when we get the
baby room completely set up I will give
you guys a tour of that but it's pretty
exciting you know I keep saying it I'm
scared I'm excited I'm nervous I'm
thrilled there's just so many different
feelings I have about um you know man
having a baby you know what I mean like
it's just it's an amazing feeling that I
can't really oh let me take this
off that I can't really uh put put into
proper words but you know for all you
moms and dads out there that listen to
the podcast you know appreciate you guys
for being here and you know you you'll
help me on my
journey okay let's go to comments y'all
let's go to the comments love it let's
see Daniel Turner
4264 perfect name hit that's a name
thank you I love you Griff keep on
keeping on I appreciate those kind of
comments let me give that a Hearts Up
uh so then you have like so he said that
but then he also had a negative comment
where he's like if no good guests do a
crazy touchy subject I personally
haven't watched any of it in over a year
you know so it is what it is you know
this is what's going to happen but I
will address that like you know I I'm
probably gonna I want to Rebrand the
podcast I mean I've done I'm getting
close to 300 episodes and I'm like all
right do I want to keep doing it like
this or do I want to have something
specific so I almost feel like I want to
Rebrand riffin with Griffin and just
just make it about TVs and movies or you
know and or it's an occasionally have
guests you know I don't know I have to
figure it out but having guests is hard
because I do it here at my place and I
don't want to now that I'm about to have
a baby I know Rachel's going to be like
I don't want strangers coming here even
people that we know so I don't I don't
know if I'm going to have guests you
know like that or I have to figure out
like going someplace else I kind of like
doing it remotely remote with Griffin
cuz I did that when I went to Dane
Cook's house and I interviewed him at
his place and I loved that episode just
because of like the the nature of it so
I got to I got to I'm still figuring it
out y'all I'm still figuring it out but
you know we'll see what what I want to
do or maybe I just don't even want to do
this anymore too you know that's another
that's another option so we'll
see um so there's somebody like the you
know this is one of these like fact
check things we have to do but MAV
Miller says nicotine is actually healthy
for your brain it's the only chemical in
cigarette that are bad news love the
show love your takes on even if they're
aren't based off straight facts but hey
it's Griffin with Griffin not the 100%
factually scientifically correct
show I love that comment that's great
and that's so true thank you for even
saying that this is not the 100%
factually scientifically correct show
thank you this is just my thoughts I I
don't I'm no expert you know and when it
comes to like nicotine and stuff like
that or even like um uh caffeine and
coffee there's moderation I don't think
that like just because nicotine there's
something in nicotine that might be good
for your brain uh but like way to cost
so like imagine like you're like a
smoker and you're like this is helping
my brain but then it's causing lung
cancer and throat cancer and and like
you know a strain on the economy of
billions of dollars in medical and all
that stuff because of what smoking
causes I mean that you have to waigh the
pros and cons so
yeah there might be that might be true
you know that might be there might be
some like hey this is the are there any
benefits of nicotine but that's not the
same as what people are doing the
smoking the the carcinogen effect of
like the the the the burning of the
paper and all that kind of stuff so it's
more nuanced than what this guy's saying
but I totally get it but what he just
said is no reason to continue for people
to be smoking I don't know it's just
like I think smoking is terrible you
know what I mean if you're a smoker out
there it is what it is but you know
you're addicted like you know what I
mean like I like a true smoker a true
like it's just like my relationship with
food it's the same kind of thing like
I'm not saying ban food right but it's
like at a certain point like if you're
having health issues because of your
choices I think the medical system
should count that into effect I think
like when you go to the doctor right and
you've been eating like a fat [__] for
like you know five years of your you
know the last 5 years and then the
doctor's like wow we have to do this
this like we have to do so many things
because of that we have to because of
you now you have heart issues now you
have you know your blood pressure and
all these things that you you shouldn't
have the same deductible in insurance as
somebody who's been say taking care of
thems they've been I'm not saying they
got to be [__] you know Superman
physically fit but they're you know
they're eating right you know they're
drinking a lot of water they're
exercising they got good heart health
they got you know that that kind of
person like that kind of person that
stuff should be on their insurance right
so the insurance should be like you know
hey we we're going to pay for like they
should pay for the gym you know what I
mean like your insurance should pay for
your gym membership or like it like you
know how if something happens to you and
you get like you could go to a therapist
because you know if you have issues you
go to a therapist if you uh you know if
your back your back is hurt you go to a
chiropractor you go to like physical
therapy or you go to like you know
sometimes they put massages on the
insurance for that put the gym on there
make the gym part of that wouldn't that
be great then you have incentive to stay
healthy cuz ultimately you don't want to
use your insurance at all unless it's
like you're in a car accident or you had
some kind of thing but like what a
strain on the medical system that
somebody who's actively not taking care
of themsel and then some bad [__]
happens in the result of that and they
go to the hospital and now they're down
they're straining the medical system
because of their choices you know I'm
saying okay you pay for insurance but
like that deductible should be high I
don't know there you and that's what I
feel about smoking you know it's like
those kinds of choices so I get it it's
hard to like you know I'm doing it now I
had to pay a grip I'm pay I'm paying a
trainer to keep me accountable you know
and I feel stronger but it's like I
don't physically look I haven't
physically lost the weight yet because
it's so hard oh my God how hard is it to
lose weight like crazy you know and and
then your part of it too is like you
have to like eat you have to have some
moderation in your eating God that [__]
is hard anyways but good comment good
discussion with myself
MAV oh man let's see what else do I got
here
um
whatever let's see somebody oh here we
go Universal stupid name Diddy's just
another billionaire that happened to
take advantage of people who were
vulnerable I don't think Diddy was some
re serial rapist bloodthirsty dude but
rather what happens to certain people
when you get that much influence and
wealth it's disgusting for sure but not
uncommon
yeah yeah a lot of lawsuits and stuff
coming out right now all these kind of
details I don't know if you guys saw
this like new Diddy allegation with the
Aaron Hall old school singer from the
the group guy only people from the 80s
and 90s would even know that group but
there was like another and and and the
thing I found strange about it was like
so you had like Aaron Hall and he has
this song with these like terrible
lyrics in it the lyrics don't you know
like some like most things they don't
age well you know and then it's like
kind of taken out of context of like
when you listen to the song or like
whatever his intent was but it's like
it's like you know lock the door all
this kind of it's like really like if
you listen to to the lyrics you know uh
it's crazy but the thing is it's like
you have and then
so then people are saying uh the lawsuit
from Jane Doe is like oh this song
sounds exactly like what happened to her
and so that just made me go well wait a
minute did did
uh I mean you know I mean it just sounds
like you know and I I don't want to
sound like I'm like victim blaming or
anything like that but that just sounds
strange and all of a sudden this this
window of suing people comes up it's
about to end and all these lawsuits come
up and in this law you know people on
the internet would be like oh my God
what she said sounds just like his
lyrics like what happened like so in
their mind they think that this guy
maybe and who knows this could have
happened like this but you're saying he
raped this woman and then wrote a song
about it and put it
out the other side of it is or this
woman had a somewhat had a bad encounter
with him or you know was it a what was
it a crime whatever happened I who knows
what happened and then or it's somebody
that oh here's a song Oh Let's you let's
let's make up allegations you know and
use this song so it's like you don't
know it's something that happened in the
90s it's like damn it's so it's so
tough we really got to make it easier
for
victims when this kind of stuff happens
to come out and go for justice we have
to make it easier more safe we have to
normalize it you know and then and then
to me it shouldn't go on the internet
you know it just should not go on the
internet man we shouldn't be privy to
this at all you know what I mean cuz
then people have their thoughts and
opinions podcasters are talking about it
you know what I'm saying I don't know
weird thing man anyways uh enough
comments for the week
thanks guys for leaving your
comments um you know appreciate that you
know it's just again I I just I can't
stress enough that you
know we got we we have to the the
system's broken in my opinion okay it's
broken for the victims and it's broken
for people who this didn't happen the
way they said and then now they're being
vilified in the public eye you know what
I mean because how how bad would that be
too so let's say let's say in a certain
case that a victim is actually lying and
they are it is a money grab that they're
trying to get they put this information
out now this person's life can be ruined
because of the internet you know that's
not fair either you know especially we
don't know what happened you know what I
mean and then and the other side of it
is like here's like these victims who
you know something terrible happened to
them and now they you know so now they
have to be John Jane Doe but then the
information gets out and now they're
being attacked on the internet they're
being called a liar they're being called
to like and then so you have other real
VI you have other real victims out there
who are like who who didn't get raped by
Diddy you know what I mean they just got
they got assaulted by you know their
cousin or or the Dude down the street
who has no money what recourse do they
have you know what I mean so it's like
these like high-profile cases are not
helping regular people I'm so tired of
these dumb comments like go girl yeah
girl it's about time you could like
that's not helping like there's actually
somebody out there who was like damn my
boss raped me my uh you know my neighbor
or or like you know all these terrible
situations that happened and they don't
have any way to come out and like it
goes on the internet and we're all
talking about it oh that neighbor is
terrible we should no they're scared
they're they they know they're not going
to be believed and and it's like but you
know nobody's championing for them so
stop acting like these high-profile
cases are helping victims cuz in my
opinion they
aren't you know they are not they're
they aren't they're not helping they're
not doing the thing that you think
they're doing and if you just want to
Champion that one rich famous girl who's
now richer and more famous okay great go
go go girl but like don't act like
that's helping them victims cuz it's
not went off right there huh guys um oh
man I want to talk now about this like
weird documentary I'm watching on HBO
it's called mother God on HBO it's about
this weird ass cult man and you know
every time I like see documentaries
about Colts the thing that makes them
like fascinating and creepy or when they
talk to the people that are in it still
believe it still Champion it and you're
listening to them talk and you're
like wow you're crazy you know that's
just how you think about it you know so
like so this's this cult called Cult of
mother God right and the cult was called
wait let me look at my thing here what
was it called again it was the it was
the love has won oh no that's the name
of uh that wasn't the name of the that
but that was like her message I forgot I
don't I don't see the name oh yeah that
was it it was cult The Cult of love has
won you know and there was this woman
and she like was all about taking drugs
you know like like psychedelics you know
what I mean and then she had these
people believing that she was
God you know and then when you hear the
people talk about her you're like and
the documentary opens up where the cops
the documentary opens up with like
police footage these cops are like it's
it's body cam footage you know like real
and they and they go to this cult's
place you know what I mean and the cult
Guy The Cult followers they're there and
they're just like hey hello you know
they're they're acting all like
nothing's wrong basically and the cops
are like okay we have a search warrant
and they find This Woman's mummified
body wrapped up and with with like a
altar cuz they think she's coming back
to life or something you know like I
haven't got to the like the nitty-gritty
of the docu the the next episodes but
like that's where they're at okay and
then and then the documentary starts to
talk about where she came from they go
to her mom and they see you know and and
then you know there's always like I love
one of these documentaries that have the
one guy to realize this was bat [__]
crazy and he's like I can't yeah this
was uh I don't know what I was doing
type of thing I love it's like that
Nexium documentary like those there's
like they call him the Nexium
these are these people that still
believe that guy uh Keith Renard is
innocent you know like they still
believe in him
so you go you have these sort of
charismatic leaders and they use their
power of whatever that charm and
Charisma is they just use it for the
wrong purposes they use it for evil
basically you know it just happens you
know a lot of people have like like Tom
Cruz right he got that thing
like you ever seen him like talk
interviews the dude's charismatic that's
why we that's why he's a movie star so
some people become movie stars you know
some people become Hitler you know what
I mean some people become Martin Luther
King Jr so like that same skill set is
in these cult people and they have these
people believing that they are whatever
they say they are that they're God that
they're like it's like some existential
plane this one girl is showing pictures
in the documentary of like Robin
Williams and Marilyn Monroe and she's
like going down the list to being like
you know mother God these people are a
part of what mother God is talking about
it is the most bizarre thing and I think
the most bizarre thing about it is the
fact that they still believe it like
whatever like is mentally up with the
the lady and her name is Amy her real
name is Amy Carlson
Amy Carlson was just like she just was
she was she wasn't there allog together
the drugs messed with her and you know
she believed in conspiracies and she
believed in Aliens like they got footage
of her looking at the clouds and she's
like like oh but there's the spaceships
and you know all that kind of stuff
right you're just like oh my God you
know you know and you just like and you
hear the other people that are talking
about it and they're so passionate and
like you just go like when you see
people people that you can't convince of
reality you can't convince them of
reality at all that's when you get
Disturbed so I would suggest watching it
there's it's it's creepy and disturbing
and fascinating you know what a
fascinating documentary to like really
see to kind of hear the from people's
own mouth what they think
about
um this person and their reality man you
know like this and this things you know
cuz the film the series against and they
started shooting the series 3 weeks
after Amy's body was found in a
mummified position and it says
reportedly the cult um and she was a
former manager of McDonald's preserved
body was discovered by authorties inside
a Colorado Home in
2021 by the way yeah this ain't 50 years
ago 20 years ago this kind of stuff is
still going on now you know this
Colorado Home in
2021 and it says her father followers
kept her body in a makeshift Shrine
because they thought she was Mother God
sent to save humanity and has now
ascended to a superior realm of
existence you know you hear that and you
go I mean there are Skeptics out there
like how is that any different from say
Catholics who think there's a
heaven I guess it just depends
on I guess it depends on how the cult or
religion how it affects people's lives
directly and how they now then
interacting in society so if you're like
go to church every Sunday Easter Sunday
Mother's Day you go to church every
Sunday you go to church on Wednesdays
you're part of a church group and you
know you have this community but you
look you're still living in regular
neighborhoods you're still paying your
taxes you're still following the laws
more power to you right but I don't
think there's that much difference
between the only difference between what
this lady is saying about God the
universe and and say a Baptist Methodist
Catholic Jew Arab I mean sorry Muslim
who all the religious that these people
were taking a lot of drugs not paying
taxes you know leaving dead bodies in
campers thinking they're you know a
shrine I mean you know what I mean and
and then how people's lives were
affected in a very negative way you know
money was being you know there like you
know what I mean like that's I think is
that what makes a cult when it becomes
illegal or you know how is
Catholicism how is Catholicism any
different from this cult you know how
you know because and then you hear
someone talk about when you hear someone
talk about like you know you know God
knows the way and you have to do live
your life for God you hear someone talk
like that and then you hear someone in a
cult how is it any different I mean I'm
just asking you guys so please leave in
the comments I would like to know I
would like to know what you think the
differen is because to me it seems like
you know they're very similar right but
yeah I know and then some Sean caned in
the chat they said there are 10,000
Cults in America yeah I mean crazy right
but I wonder if in those Cults do they
count Methodist Baptist Catholic you
know what I mean I mean it's like I
don't
know it's crazy when you think about it
but you know you get into
conspiracy um yeah the first episode of
the of the thing that I'm watch that I
watched it was like the episode focuses
on Carson's evolving connections with
several father Gods now that's another
thing so she thought she was Mother God
that God is a woman and it's her The
Reincarnation on Earth and whatever man
she's with that she's having like a lot
of sex with this is now father God you
know so that's when you start going like
okay what are we talking about here you
know what I mean so I I do suggest
watching it it's pretty fascinating
documentary man fascinating
so yeah
man um all right so let me get into this
one thing I wanted to talk about here so
I put up a video okay so I want to talk
okay next thing now is this so you know
as a comic I would say you know there's
a lot of talk about people being
sensitive and it's like you know cancel
culture and all that kind of stuff it's
like whatever right you know I'm not
going to bore you with that talk but I
just want to give you a Comics
perspective on one thing though it's
like you know sometimes people misr
sometimes people misrepresent you they
say you're doing something that you're
not really doing just because they saw
it that way and the internet has given
voice to that so now there people are in
your comments saying all kinds of
nonsense but I was on T I was on a tour
with Matt R you know so I went we went
we were in um I forgot where we were we
were in like uh Columbus or we were in
Cincinnati we're in Cincinnati right and
this um
this lady you know and and Matt does a
lot of crowd work you know so he's doing
crowd work at the time and this lady in
the crowd right you know she's like
everybody's screaming out and this lady
starts this this interaction off with
this is our one night off from the
hospital that's what she says you can
see it on the screen this is our one
night off from the hospital I hope you
can hear this uh I think I have the
sound working right but it might be
messed up but you know it is what it is
I'm trying my best here but let's just
go through it okay I want to play the
video and I'm going to talk about it all
right you nurses are
victims okay so I want to go through
this video so the lady says it's our one
night off from the hospital my first
thought is oh are you nurses cuz you
know that's what it sounds like it's our
one night off from the hospital and I'm
like are you nurses Matt makes a jokes
are you guys VI victims it's a comedy
show trying to be funny right but is it
out of pocket to ask are you guys nurses
you know because when you when you use
those words it's our one night off this
is what the lady
says I want to know what you do at the
hospital what do you do at the
hospital oh you're oh wow God
damn so now in the middle of a comedy
show the lady
says uh it's our one night off from the
hospital I ask oh you what do you guys
do at the hospital are you nurses right
this is innocent enough interaction cuz
we're doing crowd work and we're trying
to see what you know hey what do you do
let's try to make fun she then proceeds
to tell us our kid has
cancer
okay I respond like
this wow so you left your kid with
cancer at the
hospital it's so come see Matt right do
dude you cute as a
[__]
that's
okay so now oh wait look look how I look
weird here on my on my vid on my thing
yeah so now you know she says that you
know so I respond I respond with what I
responded with right you know I respond
with that I respond with like well damn
you know you left your and now the point
I'm making is immediately after that cut
to the mom in the crowd who just said
all this going like
this laughing she's she's visibly going
like this that's great you made you
know I wish I can like you can't I I
wish you can't control Instagram like
that you can't control it like like or I
could just like go back to see that I i'
have to play the whole thing again and I
don't want to but um I mean you you see
what I'm saying man you know like like
what are we talking about you know like
uh so you know this lady she says that
she's like you know uh you know my kid
you know what I mean and you're just
kind of like all right well okay um your
your your your kid has cancer and you're
at the you're at a comedy show because
you want to make yourself feel better
that's how I looked at it you know
you're at a comedy show and you just you
just kind of want to like laugh because
it's been tough you you're you're always
at the
hospital um right you're always at the
hospital and this is what's going on and
you know and she clearly is laughing and
having a good time uh in this in this
moment
right so cut two now let me go off of
this you know I'm checking comments
every now and then and this is this is
what I mean about being
misrepresented you know what I mean
um so somebody would say like oh man
you're making fun of kids with
cancer that's not what
happen I'm making fun of this woman who
left her kid with cancer to come to a
comedy
show there's no jokes about the kid this
is about her behavior this is about like
wow so you left your kid and you came to
do a comedy show that's what the joke's
about and here's some [__] idiots in
the chat now still not
understanding what's the poor choice so
in the chat this guy poor choice bro
tell me what the poor choice is so so
here's the the
facts a woman
presents us with hey this is our one
night off at the hospital okay this is
our one night off I say what do you do
at the hospital are you a nurse no our
kid has cancer so at that point what are
we supposed to
do okay so then my point is wow so
you're here at a comedy show and your
kid is at the hospital with cancer I'm
making fun of her and she loved it cut
to her head head back clapping and
laughing like in her mind like I needed
this like thank you yes I've been having
a tough time because my kid has cancer
and thank you for making me feel good
right now but you snowflake [__] see
this and your first thought is I have to
pretend like I'm a good person so let me
go on the internet and let everybody
know oh
this is terrible I can't believe you
said that what did I actually
say I
mean this it's it's so as a comic I'm
telling you that this ain't about cancel
culture this ain't about people being
sensitive or or or overly sensitive it's
not about that at all this is about what
are your intentions like this is about
misrepresenting someone to make yourself
feel like you're being a good
person it's absolutely insane you
know there we go I hear the buzz it's
absolutely insane you know so I'm I was
had a little interaction with the guy on
Instagram who was like going in on me oh
keep that same energy of you're a kid
Hey listen man I I've been you know let
me tell you I've told this story before
but I tell you again you know when I
knew for sure I wanted to be a comedian
that I had a
gift I worked at a school and this kid
was tragically killed he was in a
go-kart in the middle of the street and
he got hit by a car he was in a coma he
didn't survive okay and they asked me to
do read his eulogy at this funeral and
when a child dies guys it is terrible
and they know more people a lot of times
when somebody old dies unless they're
like famous or they're like influential
in their Community or something a lot of
times for us regular people you die and
there's like six people at the funeral
because you know it's an older person
and they don't really know they their
their reach you kind of like when you
get older you you start to like make
your circle very tight right with with
kids oh man they just they know so many
people and there so many
anyway I'm about I'm sitting in I'm
sitting in the um they they gave me the
thing I needed to read and they wanted
me to read this and then talk about him
I'm sitting in this funeral I'm sitting
in this church and like it is just sad I
loved this kid you know and I'm freaking
telling myself don't cry get through
this Griffin you can do
this then you know this they said the
priest will call you up you know so I'm
sitting in this church and I'm like okay
you got this just relax you know what I
mean you could do it get through this be
strong for the family they play a Maria
okay
[Music]
you know what I mean Niagara Falls I'm
balling now at the in the middle of the
song I'm balling and then the priest
goes Eric and I'm like are you kidding
me so I got to walk up in front of all
these people I'm crying my eyes out you
know and I go up and read this eulogy
and he's survived by his great
grandmother and there's everyone's
sitting there you know and then I had to
talk about him you know this it was time
to talk about him you know and I just
and he was like a he was a bad kid you
know what I mean like he would get in
trouble a lot you know not bad like you
know he's robbing people and I mean like
you know just like a normal young
grandmar school
kid but he was also a ladies man you
know and then I just remember started to
talk about him I was like yeah you know
he's probably getting you know he's
probably in trouble right now cuz like
all his girlfriends are here and
something happened the the the audience
started
laughing you know and I was telling
stories of what I remember him and it
was and it was moments when people were
just like oh that's that's the kid we
know and blah blah blah and I thought to
myself damn I'm killing at this funeral
and I was like oh man this a gift you
know not everybody can do this right but
like there might be someone there who
was like oh we we shouldn't be laughing
right now but just because you think
that doesn't mean I'm a terrible person
cuz in my mind I'm spreading Joy you
know and the family coming up afterwards
and being like thank you so much you
know what I mean so it's like it's all
perspective you know but the thing is
don't misr represent what I'm doing to
try to make yourself feel better like in
this clip I can't stand when people come
like oh you're talking about kids with
KC like it's like hey from me to you go
[__] yourself because that's not what's
happening right now you know here's a
mother who obviously is going through
something tragic her child is in the
hospital with
cancer and to make herself feel better
she decided to go to a comedy show and
not only did she decide to go to a
comedy show she decided to yell out and
let us know what's going on and in turn
we made her a part of it and she loved
it but you
snowflakes want to make it out to be
something
terrible what are we talking
about I'mma leave it at
that all right guys let's finish off
with some NBA and NFL talk I love I you
know what I love what's going on right
now in the NFL so we had High Hopes in
the beginning of the Season we thought
the Jets would be good Aon Rogers gets
hurt we thought Cincinnati would be good
uh Joe burrow gets hurt he has a leg
problem they're team starts taking
losses and now he's out for the season
you know we thought a lot of these teams
would be a lot better than they are we
we thought certain teams would be good
and then the season sort of unfail
unfolds and now here we are uh with a
home stretch into the playoffs and
there's some really good football stuff
going on right now so right now um I
would say I think we're all in agreement
that the philad pH Adelphia Eagles are
probably the best team in football right
now record-wise they're 10 and one but
like five of the games so there's two
ways to look at it you go five of the
games they almost lost so maybe they're
not as good or you could think of it
like they are good this is how you find
ways to win that this is a lot everyone
in the league gets paid and the
Philadelphia Eagles just happen to be
doing better that in the end they win
even if they start bad they finish great
regardless they're 10 and one they look
freaking fantastic okay I think one of
the better the ne the next I think
there's two teams like there's this one
list I saw that you know and I don't
necessarily agree with the rankings but
you know you got the Philadelphia Eagles
you got the Baltimore Ravens you know
this is what we've looked for from Lamar
Jackson since he got into the league he
was unanimous MVP but he can't make the
playoffs and stay healthy I mean but he
wins in the regular season but they get
in the playoffs and he hasn't won a good
playoff game we want to see this guy get
to the to to the championship but but it
was always like he runs too much he's a
runner he's a runner he's a runner he
maybe he's not a great quarterback they
finally got a great offensive
coordinator in there in there they got
some weapons they freaking drafted a
wide receiver they got U what's his name
um um um what's it what's the dude's
name dude the one-and catch guy from New
York uh
obj uh you know they got him so now
they're like now they're they're
freaking nine and three like so like
they look great their defense is Stellar
I mean that's what Bal is known for his
defense so they got a great defense they
got a top uh offense is this the year
and then San Francisco I think those are
the three those are the three top tier
teams like top top tier teams uh and San
Francisco's great they're they're
they're eight and three right now and
they just can't stay healthy you know
you know you got this like rookie
quarterback he's finally played a full
season of football games wise and Brock
pie and we'll see is he great is he good
is he really good is the team just great
holding him up either either way it
doesn't matter from top to bottom San
Francisco has a top-notch roster so I
feel like San Francisco is going to be
there in the end and then of course
Kansas City who is always good Patrick
Mahomes might be the greatest
quarterback ever when it's all said and
done uh he's already got an argument
even with out having Seven Super Bowls
like Tom Brady just because he is the
sole reason why they they they win you
know the like three of the first first
three Super Bowls for Tom Brady maybe
even four they had like a top they had a
top five defense top 10 defense
at minimum you know and he was a ball
control he didn't start becoming like
pass the ball down the field uh you know
making scoring a bunch of points you
know till later you know you know what I
mean so but from jump from now Patrick
Mahomes is the reason they win you know
so it's like he's a great Quarterback
Tom Brady Patrick Mahomes right so CA
but Kansas City they get the most drops
in the league the the re receiver they
don't have a really great number one
receiver other than their tight end
Travis Kelce so I don't know if they
it's going to be a lot for them to win
and then you of course you got the
Dallas Cowboys who have a generational
defense but listen they've choked for 29
years
straight 29 years straight the Dallas
Cowboys choke in the playoffs that's all
we're going to say about that Miami
Dolphins another team Miami and Dallas
have the same issue neither one of these
teams have beat a good team so until
they actually beat a good team we don't
know if they're going to be good or not
and then these outskirts Fringe teams
that are really doing good it's like the
Jacksonville Jacksonville Jaguars love
them I think that they're Trevor
Lawrence is balling you know Doug
Peterson not Doug Peterson is that who
the coach is yeah he used to be the
coach of the Eagles when he won the
championship yes Doug Peterson he knows
how to coach that type of quarterback he
got Nick folds to the win the Super Bowl
right so I feel like Jacksonville could
be one of those teams if they snuck in
to the AFC Championship game and won I
wouldn't be surprised you know but again
Detroit Lions another team up and down
but they're eight and three what a great
turnaround we felt like they could make
it they didn't make the playoffs last
year they made the they're probably
going to make the playoffs this year
they're probably going to win that
division so Detroit we'll see I just
don't think Detroit has what it takes to
beat those top tier teams or even Dallas
so we'll see and then you got the
Pittsburgh Steelers man Pittsburgh
Steelers
can I tell you something they they are
the most boring unfund team to watch but
they're seven and four but I just I
think when it gets down to it they're
not it's like the Steelers the Cleveland
Browns oh DeShaun Watson got hurt that's
another one that they were on their way
they had the number one defense but they
can't win without deshun Watson who
knows Texans they got a great story but
they're now six and five but they got
this rookie quarterback rookie coach
rookie rookie number one receiver the
future looks bright for them but I don't
know and then you got B and then I'll
end it off with like Buffalo who is like
six and six and I just I'm done with
them if you're a buffalo fan get out my
face Buffalo reminds me of Dallas in a
way of like you always think they're
going to be good and then they always
choke so I don't know um but you know
I'm really
enjoying um uh this season of football I
don't I don't know who's going to win it
I wouldn't like in the AFC I'm not going
to be surprised if Kansas City is there
again you know you know what I mean if
Kansas City's there again we're just
going to be like well and like somebody
in the chat says that they defense yeah
this is the best Kansas City defense
they've ever had including all the Super
Bowl appearances this is their best so
that's really helping them so we'll see
you know what I mean we'll see but
um I don't know we'll see how we'll see
how it goes man but you know this is
it's been great I really enjoy it and
then uh uh lastly I'll finish with the
NBA I think the NBA has been pretty
enjoyable too with this midseason
tournament which is s of kind of soccer
es football European football you know
rest of the world football esque having
like a tournament to it I love it
because it makes the the regular season
mean something they got 500,000 on the
line so every player on the team will
get
$500,000 if they win
and the grand schema thing doesn't sound
like a lot of money for like the top
paid players on the team you know Steph
Curry's making like 40 something million
dollars 500,000 to him might be like oh
this would be cool to win you know but
if not but you know what number 7 8 9 10
11 12 on the team they probably only
making 500,000 so like or even if they
making a million dollars in the season
if they win and those guys get 500,000
that's like wow so I think the
mid-season tournament is making the
middle of the Season mean something I
think it's a great idea I think they got
to change like some of the Like rules in
terms of like tie Breakers and things
like that uh but you know in it accounts
towards your regular season record it's
not it's nothing different they're still
playing basketball games they just put
some value on the basketball games and I
think it's great so we'll see what
happens when whoever makes the
championship that's the only extra game
will be this championship game in Vegas
so that sounds great right imagine that
they going to fill the stadium and it's
going to be like this Championship
attitude feel I mean and this is what
goes on with soccer soccer has all these
like midseason tournaments and cups and
you know and then they have like the
main one but if this I think this could
be great they got the TV deal coming up
so I think that's why they're doing this
to trying to show the networks hey this
could be something big because they
already added that playin I think the
playin has been the best thing for the
NBA it's so good because the last four
weeks of the Season it now means
something because now you could be a
12th seed and you're like three games
out of the 10th spot to make the play in
you you have something to play for
before you're 12th seed you're just like
H now it's all about like well now I got
to be professional to play well but let
now you're given a chance to everyone
basically to try to make the playoffs it
inspires the fans base it you know it
keeps everybody like oh man this is this
this is great my team can still make the
playoffs so I think that these two
things they've added to the NBA has made
the NBA a little more exciting a little
more watchable and then it's great to
see like all these different teams who
are like stepping up and and and have
better teams too so there's a lot
there's actually a lot more parody in
the NBA like the magic are are 12 and
five right now like what the magic out
of nowhere they're like a seven game
winning streak they're balling and then
finally getting like again here's the
Suns Kevin Durant hurt I talk about this
all the time Kevin Durant will never
play 82 games again for the rest of his
career okay so he'll miss like 20 30
games every single year because he's 35
and he plays hard it just is what it is
and then it's like that guy uh that they
traded for uh what's his name from the
Washington um Bradley Beal this dude
hasn't even played it's like what
anyways Celtics still good so you got
magic the Suns the Celtics Celtics
they've been good 14 to four can they
get over the hump we'll see Timberwolves
are playing good they got a winning
record right now 76ers got rid of James
Harden got all those bench pieces from
the Clippers they're balling they're 12
and five right now Oklahoma Oklahoma
City Thunder that's one of those sleeper
teams everybody's been talking about
they got a winning record the bucks with
Damen Lillard they're still figuring out
but they're number two in the east you
got the Kings who were number two last
year they're still balling right now and
the rockets the Rockets who like they're
getting their [__] together you know uh
what's his name they you know they
finally their coach their Celtics coach
from laska aoku who like had that little
nonsense happen you know and then you
got the Nuggets you know the Knicks the
Pelicans the Mavericks the Lakers Lakers
are 10 and8 you know the Pacers are good
I mean there's so many teams that are
like one or two games above 500 those
and that that makes that means it's
going to be like oh wow this is going to
be down the stretch I think it's going
to be a
fantastic end of the regular season for
NBA so I totally look forward to
that but anyway my friends um you know
how we do um I'll keep you guys posted
you know oh my car my car is still great
I still love
it
you know people like Wonder like oh you
you you know you still got that car you
know what do you think about your Lucid
I think the lucid's great I just wish I
could have gotten um what do you call it
I wish I could have gotten the uh this
new SUV that they have that SUV is dope
dude I love that
SUV all right guys man what's going on
with my now my computer is messing up I
can't get to my live
stream uh it says about the page is not
responding what is going on man why is
it my okay here we go all right here we
go um all right let me let me close this
here we go finally I'm
back
um oh my car yeah the car is super fast
for chat that's asking me about that car
is super duper fast but guys I want to
thank everybody for watching the
podcast uh every single week you know
you guys have been
super you know super
supportive super supportive and I
appreciate always and you know there's
many different ways to support the show
so please be a subscriber subscribe to
um the podcast on so you can get the
notifications make sure you hit the make
sure you hit the notifications so you
know what's going on when when I'm going
live so that's important you know I'm on
Twitch I'm about to be I'm I'm gonna go
on Twitch in a little while here as soon
as I get off this I'm going to get
myself something to drink and then I'm
going to get on
um wait I'm looking I'm looking for my
music then I'm going to get on um the P
the twitch so make sure you check that
out and also you can be a supporter on
patreon if you want to help support me
and the show all of those proceeds will
go to baby stuff
so I totally and always appreci
appreciate that so you know what time it
is guys here on riffin with
Griffin Yeah
Yeah Chris you beat Chris you
beat r with
Griffin with that rap
recap we look
back tell you about all those
facts NFL is looking
good I wish he would
[Music]
and
NBA hey it look
okay
uh what if I was one of those rappers
anyways guys thanks for watching you
know don't be a
snowflake remember it's okay for other
people that have different
opinions I guess I say that to myself
too but thanks for watching we're from
Griffin and I will see
you next week thank you chisu for this
meat all right y'all take
[Music]
care